bonjour je m'appelle Kadi et bonjour je
m'appelle Pharrell et du coup Gad
Elmaleh on voulait de te demander ça t'a
fait quoi de rencontrer la famille
royale à Monaco et tout ça a duré dingue
genre en mode ça devrait être une
dinguerie
bon alors super question de caddie et
Pharrell des gens on va parler de vos
prénoms les gars franchement ils sont
stylés je sais pas d'où vous les avez
sortis c'est un moment que moi je prends
beaucoup de plaisir à jouer et que je
trouve très très drôle c'est là où
j'avais les plus gros rire tous les
soirs c'est un moment qui est assez
tendre aussi parce que je le fais avec
beaucoup de bienveillance aussi
mais je me moque plus de nous et du
syndrome du blédard que je décris dans
le dans le spectacle donc les gars je
vous laisse regarder le spectacle et
vous me direz ce que vous pensez de
cette grande rencontre entre ma mère et
le Prince de Monaco
[Musique]